[Music]
breaking news this Friday night Justice
for Amanda Todd the Dutch man who
tormented and sexually extorted the BC
teen is punished this has been 10 years
since her death the concerns
complicating his fate
the long-term consequences of the Convoy
protest loss of hearing balance vertical
Ottawa residents in their own words
a break in a 22 year old Cold Case the
new charges in a Quebec woman's death
and the new questions about the prime
suspect and he fought indigenous
stereotypes through film for those of
you who've never seen anything I've done
before the influence of migma movie
director Jeff Barnaby
foreign
Asser
good evening thank you for joining us
Ten Years After BC teenager Amanda Todd
ended her own life the Dutch Man
convicted in her cyber bullying and
extortion has been sentenced by a
Canadian judge Iden koban handed 13
years in prison to be served after
another jail sentence in the Netherlands
for Amanda's dad today's decision
represents Justice and he describes his
emotion as happy
I was hoping and praying we got a high
sentence and we did but our expectations
were lower
so everybody pulled together and we got
through to the judge and set a really
high presidents out there which is
really nice I'm really happy about that
Nita Garcia joins us now from New
Westminster BC neither you were in the
courtroom describe the reaction as the
sentence was read
while Farah there were gasps that could
be heard in The Pact public Gallery as
Justice Martha Devlin handed Iden koban
a 13-year Global sentence to be served
consecutively after his existing 11-year
sentence in the Netherlands on similar
charges ends on in August of 2024. now
it's important to note that this
sentence is much higher than the 12-year
sentence sought by Crown prosecutors and
much higher than the two years sought by
defense but coban's lawyers say their
unique legal circumstances here because
this sentence will now go before a Dutch
judge in the Netherlands who will
convert it to a Dutch sentence Amanda
Todd's mother Carol had told us she
worries that he may not end up spending
a day in prison Beyond his existing
Dutch sentence regardless she says she
feels that today is a day of justice for
her daughter
and I thought I would wear it today for
luck and it worked wearing her good luck
charm the same necklace her daughter
Amanda wore in this photo Carol Todd
reacting to the judge handing Iden koban
a sentence of 13 years to be served
after his existing Dutch term for
similar charges in the Netherlands it
was amazing because it was Justice for
Amanda it's higher than the 12-year
sentence Crown prosecutors argued for
and much higher than the two years
sought by defense but now this Canadian
sentence will go before a judge in the
Netherlands this sentence is way more
than the maximum in the Netherlands
I'm will they accept that I don't know
the Dutch Man convicted by a 12-member
jury in August in the 15 year old cyber
bullying 44 year old Iden koban was
extradited from the Netherlands to face
charges of extortion harassment child
luring and possession and distribution
of child pornography
has such a high profile thanks to Amanda
her mother sat in court because Amanda
chose to tell her story in a YouTube
video before her death in 2012. I can't
bring Amanda back but with Amanda's
story
we can save others Todd's mother says
there will never be closure for her only
the end of one painful chapter as she
continues advocating for better
protections of child victims all over
the world
the judge began and ended her delivery
of the sentence the same way things will
move forward from here by saying while
Amanda is not with us her voice is being
heard Farah
nifugarcha and New Westminster thank you
nephew
if you were in a young person in your
life need someone to talk to you can
call kids help phone at 1-800-668-6868
turning now to Ottawa in the first day
of testimony in the public inquiry into
the federal government's controversial
use of the emergencies act in February
as Abigail Beeman reports day one was
all about hearing from those living in
the nation's capital directly affected
by the Convoy protests that took over
the corps for weeks
for a few seconds at a time throughout
testimony the inquiry listened to the
horns the people in downtown Ottawa
listened to for days sometimes non-stop
it was just day-to-day living within my
own home living in fear no Taxi
no Uber
no para transfer no grocery delivery
which I depended on Victoria de Laurent
has a visual impairment she says the
Convoy diminished her independence and
left her with long-term hearing loss
vertigo and other problems long after
the trucks finally left I was able
before to listen to Media for example at
a normal level of say four now I have to
turn it to six I just didn't feel that
there was any support available for us
Ottawa city councilors and Business
Leaders repeatedly spoke about
businesses Frozen and residents asking
for help facing a lack of response a
lack of support and a lack of
information from police and the city the
Ottawa Police Service was heavily
criticized throughout the Convoy at the
inquiry their lawyer pushed back a
ticket though that you would agree with
me that there may be circumstances under
which there are impediments to police
disclosing certain information to local
businesses but there were multiple
eyebrow raising examples of inaction
like from the Ottawa counselor who had
protesters show up at his home and
decided to move himself and his family
away for safety he reported the
situation to Ops but he never heard back
from them former police chief Peter
slowly's lawyer pushed back on a claim
the chief said he was scared early on in
a convoy phone call I remember being
scared personally
because I'm the chief saying at one
point you guys are scared I get it I'm
scared too he's going to say he didn't
say that right that instead he was
expressing why he understood people were
frightened day one of testimony in a
long six-week stretch and remember the
goal is to examine the federal
government's decision to invoke the
emergencies act starting off next week
more representatives from the city of
Ottawa including the mayor Abigail
Beeman Global News
Ottawa
one day after the January 6 committee
voted unanimously to subpoena Donald
Trump the former U.S president is
skirting the question of whether or not
he'll testify instead he's doubling down
on baseless claims of election fraud in
the form of a lengthy and hostile
response in a 14-page letter Trump
expresses his team's anger
disappointment and complaint that the
committee has not spent even a short
moment examining what he calls the
massive election fraud that took place
during the 2020 election instead saying
the panel targeted only those who were
protesting the fraud itself
the committee is expected to issue The
subpoena sometime next week and if he
doesn't comply Trump could face criminal
charges
British prime minister Liz truss has
fired her Finance Minister after only 38
days on the job and she's reversing
course on sweeping tax cuts it's a move
that will scrap a key part of her
economic plan that triggered turmoil on
the markets and sent the pound to record
lows
but it is clear that parts of our mini
budget went further and faster the
markets were expecting
so the way we are delivering our mission
right now has to change
trust says the corporate tax will rise
to 25 that's in line with the previous
government's plan under a mini budget
the tax would have been frozen at 19
from a foreign Health secretary Jeremy
Hunt has been named the new Finance
Minister there
a new report from the international
monetary fund is sounding the alarm
about potential economic problems in
this country the United Nations agency
is forecasting substantial cooling over
the next year which could push the
economy into a mild recession Canada's
Deputy Prime Minister spent the week in
Washington discussing ways to protect
the global economy Eric Sorensen has
more on Christian freeland's plan to
strengthen Canada's ties with
like-minded Nations
a blunt gloomy message from the
international monetary fund on the
global economy in short the worst is yet
to come and for many people 2023 will
feel like a recession much of the blame
is directed at Russia for its invasion
of Ukraine an equally blunt message
today from Canada's Finance Minister
that Russia should be out of the G20 it
has no place at the G20 table Freeland
is working with her Finance colleagues
like U.S treasury secretary Janet Yellen
and told an audience at the Brookings
institution that Global democracies
should no longer rely on economic
interdependence to change authoritarian
governments muscular dictatorships show
little sign of mellowing into liberal
democracies the world's democracies must
strengthen our connections with each
other it's being called friend Shoring
trading with like-minded Nations and not
being dependent on countries like Russia
or China especially says this analyst
for critical Goods like technology and
energy it's critical important that we
establish very firm and reliable trading
relations with our principal Partners
the United States and Europe and talking
about friend Shoring is one way to do
that in the last 20 years Canada has
reduced its export trade dependence with
the U.S from 84 percent to 77 percent of
our total exports much of that change
shifted our trade towards China
quadrupling from 580 million dollars in
exports 20 years ago to 2.4 billion
dollars this year now our relationship
with the U.S looks ever more important
once again this is one of the easiest
relationships can have is an
All-American president that easy
relationship starts with a massive
decision by the U.S this year to give
Canadian production of electric vehicles
privileged access to the U.S market
Canada also plans to produce critical
minerals for the digital and green
economy and develop Partnerships with
countries like Germany for the potential
export of Canadian hydrogen I think
you're already seeing the Practical and
positive results for Canada of Fran
Shoring if indeed a recession is coming
it looks like Canada's way out of it
will increasingly look to trade with
governments it trusts Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto it's Defenders day
in Ukraine coming up how the people
there are feeling is Russia's War drags
on
the president of Ukraine is promising
victory over Russia as the country marks
its first defender's day since the War
Began
[Music]
zielinski visited a memorial wall to all
soldiers killed on the front lines since
2014. he expressed gratitude to everyone
who's fought for Ukraine and those who
are still putting their lives on the
line
he also met with wounded troops in
person at the Maine Military Hospital in
Kiev the president thanked them for
their service and handed out awards for
courage and bravery and combat and he
also recognized medical staff for their
dedication and professionalism under
extraordinary circumstances
Ukraine has paid a terrible price with
Russian airstrikes intensifying this
week as Crystal gemancing Reports today
is for reflecting on the collective
fight for freedom
they are Ukraine's Defenders fathers
mothers friends and neighbors
we are happy about the liberation of
territories wow this is great we are
moving forward but we don't always
understand Thanks To whom it happens
Ukraine has not confirmed with the world
how many soldiers it has lost since
Russia breached its borders in February
loss is measured here in much more
intimate terms empty beds and missing
Smiles
until the end he stood and defended not
only our country City and Europe but
also our family
this day is even more important to me
now I think it's obvious because this
day has cost me the highest possible
price I've ever paid Defenders day was
first celebrated in 2015.
crane has fought separatists backed by
Russia for years in the East now every
region Bears Battle Scars daily Russian
forces shell cities and towns across
Ukraine we don't set ourselves the task
of destroying Ukraine Vladimir Putin
says no of course not many ukrainians
consider the Russian president a war
criminal who's taken all they have
we will surely spend winter here because
we have nowhere else to go nowhere to
stay this child six months old has only
known life underground the large
basement below the factory where Olaf
shevchenko's husband works lacks the
comfort of a home but offers something
priceless
protection
Crystal gomancing Global News London
SpaceX boss Elon Musk is threatening to
stop providing Ukrainian forces with
free access to its starlink satellite
internet Network the satellite network
has been a key tool for the Ukrainian
military allowing for secure rapid
communication and for the remote
operation of its Fleet of drones musk
who has tweeted several controversial
hot takes on the war says the cost to
starlink is about 20 million dollars per
day
in Nigeria widespread flooding is
devastating the nation the country's
humanitarian Ministry says more than 500
people had been killed and 1.4 million
people have been displaced the floods
have hit 27 if Nigeria's 36 States
caused by heavy rainfall poor
infrastructure and the release of water
from several dams more torrential rains
expected in the coming weeks the rainy
season there typically Ends by December
[Music]
I had a suspect discharge in a
decades-old cold case in Quebec could
there be more victims
[Music]
foreign
people including an off-duty police
officer are dead after a mass shooting
in North Carolina and the suspect is a
15 year old boy he's in hospital in
critical condition according to police
the teen started shooting people
seemingly at random while walking along
Suburban Street in the City of Raleigh
in the U.S a mass shooting is defined as
a single incident in which four or more
people are killed and if we use that
metric there have been
533 mass shootings in the country so far
this year
the bodies of two Ontario police
officers killed this week while in the
line of duty are back home tonight
police officers stood in salute as a
procession carrying the remains of
Constable's Devin Northrup and Morgan
Russell made its way from Toronto to
Berry
the two officers were shot and killed on
Tuesday while responding to a call in
the town of Innisfil a joint police
funeral will be held for the pair
Quebec Provincial Police are making a
public appeal to anyone who recognizes
an accused killer Mark Andre grenon was
arrested this week and charged with the
first degree murder of a young student
22 years ago he's also been linked to
another crime and now police are
wondering if there may be more Mike
Armstrong reports
the Quebec Provincial Police Cold Case
website has 291 unsolved murders and as
of this week one the Cold Case Squad
believes it solved Guillen putvay had
just turned 19 years old in April of
2000 when she was sexually assaulted and
murdered she was a student living on
campus in John care with roommates
was alone when someone broke in
retired police officer Bruno Carmi was
the first investigator on the scene when
putvay's body was found this week he
received news he's hoped to hear for 22
years an arrest
says there's finally a certain Freedom
it was a case that still bothered every
officer involved
was picked up by police Wednesday
morning at his home in Granby Quebec the
47 year old worked at a grocery
Distribution Center
at a conference on self-help in 2017 he
described himself as having been in his
past a loner with few friends and no
support he called himself a heavy case
well Grano appeared by video conference
Thursday before a judge charged with
potvin's murder and then just minutes
later in front of a judge in another
case only three months after potvin
another student was violently sexually
assaulted in Quebec City she was left
for dead but survived gonna was charged
with attempted murder in that case
but these parents say there is a mix
right now of sadness and relief not
knowing who killed their daughter has
been hard now police linked the two
cases years ago with DNA evidence they
were just never able to link them to a
suspect there not saying how they did
that now only that technology has
improved now one thing I know mentions
in the video is that he rarely lived in
one place for long police say because he
moved often he may have committed crimes
in other parts of the province they're
now looking for other victims in other
unsolved crimes Mike Armstrong Global
News
inspiring life of an indigenous
filmmaker cut short next a legacy of
Canadian writer director Jeff Barnaby
[Music]
a Canadian director whose work changed
the conversation about indigenous
filmmaking has died Jeff Barnaby was
just 46 years old when he lost his
battle with cancer on Thursday Mike
troulet reports
what's up
wow a claim wasn't something Jeff
Barnaby was used to when he last
appeared at the Toronto International
Film Festival he had just finished his
second and ultimately last feature film
appointed critique of colonialism
wrapped in a Bloody Zombie horror called
blood Quantum and it was turning heads
for those of you who've never seen
anything I've done before I I welcome
you to the flock the movie which Barnaby
wrote directed produced and scored was
nominated for 10 at Canadian screen
Awards in one six this
is what brings my people together they
are to forgetfulness born to be a mick
ma filmmaker from Quebec burst under the
scene with the 2013 film rhymes for
young ghouls which told a story of the
residential school experience Through
The Eyes of a young girl actor DeVry
Jacobs credits Barnaby for launching her
career he not only took a chance on me
but fought relentlessly to cast me in
his debut Barnaby made a career of
fighting for indigenous stories and
representation
use adapt to creating scenes drawn from
his years growing up on a reserve
usually with a Twist like the zombie
fish in blood Quantum set in Red Crow
Barnaby's own mikma Community my first
experience that I remember was uh
being raided by the SQ during a like a a
salmon Crackdown like they thought our
our Reserve was fishing too much salmon
so it kind of it it started from there
sadly at the end it came too soon he
fought cancer for a year before dying at
age 46 just as his career was taking off
I am really pissed off that I don't get
to see his next movie that no one does
but mostly me I really wanted to see
what he would do next Barnaby made
horror movies but he wanted his audience
to wrestle with larger messages he was
trying to convey Jesse Wente of the
indigenous screen office called him a
vital figure in the Indigenous new wave
of the 2000s whose influence will be
felt for Generations
Jeff Barnaby kicked open doors to get
his films made may his success allow
others like him to walk through
micro like Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Friday night I'm far on Oster and on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
Canada is a view of the Lions Gate
Bridge in Vancouver Jeff sempel will be
at the anchor desk over the weekend
until next time take care of yourselves
and each other good night
thank you
[Music]